Transcription: Alessandro Brizzi
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Lionel Pourchier : En 2015,
les accords de Paris ont fait
renaître un formidable espoir
pour lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique.
Aujourd’hui, six ans après,
il est l’heure de déchanter.
Les scénarios nous amènent toujours
au delà de 1,5 degré de réchauffement.
Pourtant, on explore des solutions,
comme par exemple la capture
de CO2 dans l’atmosphère.
On a vu Elon Musk proposer 100 millions
de dollars pour la meilleure technologie ;
alors, nous pouvons attendre
cette solution miracle,
comme s’il y avait un vaccin
au réchauffement climatique.
Arrivera-t-elle un jour ?
Probablement pas.
Ou alors trop tard.
Pourtant, il existe une solution ici,
à quelques mètres d'ici.
Une machine incroyable qui s’est
développée au cours de millions d’années,
qui a déjà capturé 30% des émissions
de CO2 dues aux activités humaines,
qui nous rend un nombre
incalculable de services
sans jamais nous demander un seul centime,
qui couvre 70% de la planète.
Est-ce que vous voyez de quoi je parle ?
Cette solution,
c’est simplement les océans.
Un exemple : la posidonie en Méditerranée,
qui est présente sur notre littoral.
C’est la championne du monde
de la séquestration du carbone.
À surface égale,
pour un même kilomètre carré,
elle est capable de capturer trois fois
la quantité de carbone
de la forêt amazonienne.
Sans le savoir, c’est d’immenses forêts
que nous avons sur notre littoral,
ramenée à sa surface en Méditerranée,
soit 35 000 kilomètres carrés,
elle est capable de capturer chaque année
l’équivalent de 4 millions
de tonnes de CO2.
Cela représente les émissions
d’une ville de la taille de Marseille.
Frédéric Favre : En plus
d’être la championne
de la captation du carbone,
la posidonies nous rend
de nombreux services :
elle protège nos plages contre l’érosion,
elle sert de nurserie pour des centaines
d’espèces de poissons et de crustacés,
elle purifie aussi l’eau par filtration
et elle produit l’oxygène
que nous respirons.
D’après le Programme des Nations Unies
pour l’environnement,
ces écosystèmes-là,
les herbiers sous-marins,
ont plus de valeur encore
que la forêt amazonienne
ou les récifs coralliens.
Malheureusement, nous détruisons
ces écosystèmes à un rythme effréné.
Et le problème c’est que,
tout le carbone qui a été capté
pendant des millénaires dans les sédiments
est libéré dans l’atmosphère.
Détruire ces herbiers, c’est créer
de nouvelles sources d’émission de CO2
au même titre que le transport,
l’aviation, par exemple.
On estime aujourd’hui qu’on a détruit
jusqu’à 38% de la couverture des herbiers
en Méditerranée, au cours
des 50 dernières années.
Alors, comment valoriser
ce trésor sous-marin ?
Comment donner un prix à ces services
rendus par la nature ?
On dispose d’un outil,
d’une monnaie d’échange internationale,
qui est la tonne de CO2.
C’est un système qui
a déjà fait ses preuves
en milieu terrestre pour
la protection des forêts, par exemple.
Quand on protège la forêt,
on évite des émissions de CO2
et ces émissions de CO2 évitées peuvent
être converties en crédits carbone,
en certificats de compensation,
qu’on va pouvoir vendre ensuite
à des entreprises ou des privés
qui souhaitent atteindre
la neutralité carbone.
Ouvrons ce monde de la finance carbone
aux herbiers de posidonie.
au monde marin en général
et on va pouvoir ainsi
permettre aux entreprises
de financer directement des projets
de conservation de la posidonie
tout en améliorant leur bilan carbone.
Samuel Jeglot : Mais que financer
avec ces crédits carbone ?
Des solutions pour éviter les destructions
par les ancrages des navires,
des ancres qui vont labourer
les prairies sous-marines
vieilles de plusieurs centaines
à plusieurs milliers d’années.
Plus une ancre sera grosse,
plus les dégâts seront importants.
Par exemple, l’ancre d’un yacht
avec sa chaîne va détruire
jusqu’à 2 000 m²
de surface d’herbiers de posidonies
en l’espace d’une seule nuit.
Des dégâts qui sont
vraiment considérés
comme irréversibles
à l’échelle d’une vie humaine.
La préservation de la posidonie
commence par un changement
en profondeur de nos comportements.
Le simple geste de jeter son ancre
dans les herbiers de posidonies
n’est pas sans conséquences
sur cet habitat
qui grandit d’un mètre par siècle.
Il ne viendrait pas à l’idée à chaque
fois que l’on va en forêt,
de creuser un sillon dans la forêt
pour aller pique-niquer avec sa famille.
Pourtant, c’est exactement
ce qu’il se passe avec la posidonie
chaque fois qu’on va
mouiller avec son bateau.
Aujourd’hui, nous n’avons plus d’excuses.
L’ensemble des fonds côtiers
ont été cartographiés.
On est capable, à l’aide
d’une application téléphonique,
de savoir exactement où l’on veut mouiller
sans impacter la posidonie.
La formation des plaisanciers
pour un mouillage écoresponsable
est réellement une priorité.
Concilier la plaisance avec
la préservation de la posidonie
nécessite trois choses.
La première chose concerne
la réglementation.
Il faut qu'elle soit précise.
La deuxième concerne
la surveillance des navires.
Il faut qu'elle soit efficace.
Et la troisième : l’installation
d’équipements adaptés à la plaisance.
Donc, la réglementation
évolue, elle se renforce,
ce qui permet pour
la première fois d’envisager
une protection
efficace de la posidonie
à condition d’avoir
une surveillance des navires.
Interdire les mouillages, interdire
des zones pour les navires
ne va de pair qu’avec l’installation
d’équipements adaptés
parce que exclure les navires
d’une zone n’est pas une solution en soi.
Il faut éviter le report,
éviter de renvoyer cette pression
ailleurs sur le pourtour méditerranéen,
en plus d’impacter
négativement l’économie locale.
Pour les zones qui sont
fortement dégradées,
il existe des solutions
de restauration écologique.
Replanter des fragments
de posidonies trouvés en épave
permet de restaurer ces zones
qui ont été détruites.
Ces solutions, finalement,
elles ne sont pas à inventer.
Elles ne sont pas technologiques.
Elles existent.
Elles ne demandent qu'à être mises
en place, tout simplement.
Aussi bien localement que sur le pourtour
méditerranéen, à grande échelle.
La posidonie est apparue sur Terre
il y a 100 millions d’années.
Elle a traversé tout un tas de cataclysmes
au cours de différents temps géologiques.
Il y a 5 millions d’années,
la Méditerranée s’est refermée.
Elle s’est quasiment
complètement asséchée
entraînant la disparition quasi totale
des espèces, sauf la posidonie.
Ce que la nature n’a pas fait
en 100 millions d’années,
l’homme est en train de le faire tout
doucement au cours des quelques décennies.
Il est temps d’agir.
Cette posidonie, qui est
une miracle de l’évolution,
aujourd’hui c’est notre meilleure alliée
contre les dérèglements climatiques
et les conséquences
de ces dérèglements climatiques.
Il est vraiment temps aujourd’hui
de protéger cet habitat sous-marin
qui est le pilier principal
du carbone bleu en Méditerranée.
Je vous remercie.